with a red card at the ready Sangma car
proudly attaches the emblem of the
Turkish Soccer Federation on our Jersey
for the 25 year old it's a special
moment each time the linesman is getting
ready to in the tunnel outside 22 men
are waiting Saima car is nervous but
ambitious Hey no absolutely not I'm not
afraid of the players not taking me
seriously or even insulting me
for half a year
a car has been a licensed referee the
first female one in eastern Turkey today
she's reffing a regional league game in
her hometown of Hikari
first she delivers a friendly warning to
the players to keep in mind the poor
conditions and the pitch to prevent
injuries then she places the ball on the
center line the men in the stands look
skeptical but a cars 11 year old sister
Zechariah is proud a car blows the
opening whistle she's in ref to second
division game in western Turkey here
near the eastern border males still
aren't used to a woman calling the shots
a woman among all those men that's not
right I wouldn't allow my wife or sister
to do that whether Iran lies just beyond
these mountains until recently the city
of Akari was the center of violent
clashes between Kurds and the Turkish
state now they've agreed to a ceasefire
but it's mainly men who are out enjoying
the newfound peace there are few women
on the streets saying Makar is one of
them she visits a friend who works at a
travel agency a car is a bit of a
celebrity in her home city and a role
model why shouldn't women referee men's
matches of course they can - a match
Baldr cibc making the traditional pide
bread is still women's work here as a
young girl sang Makar helped in the
kitchen then she left to attend
University in western Turkey
today she's a gym teacher lives in a
neighboring city and only comes here to
eat freshly baked pita bread is a staple
food here in this poor region of Turkey
Sami makaras father is the head of this
district his other four children all
still live in Akari only Sam has moved
on when she returns home the neighbors
come to say hello the referee is the
pride of the family her father has
accepted the facts ìiím is different
than all her peers
hich Oklahoma's IMU I never dreamed
she'd be a referee one day little girl
she was always very active they never
told her that she wasn't allowed to do
this saw that because she was a girl we
supported her you're them jewelry
community F daughter model community
girls should stay at home girls
shouldn't go to school or do men's work
we have managed to overcome this kind of
thinking but it hasn't been easy
H : loving some letter at the refereeing
course in Akari most of the students are
still men though she graduated six
months ago
AHIMA Cod still comes here and brought
someone who hopes to follow in her
footsteps
Akkad wants to learn more about tricky
offside calls she hopes to ref games in
the Turkish Super League someday the
first time I came I thought what am I
doing here
how can I do this but the course
instructor believed in me and supported
me that helped me a lot back on the
pitch the match is drawing to a close
the greens are trailing one to two and
start letting out their frustration at
Zhang Mikado the game gets rougher and
she has to take action
but then the greens even up the score
and things are fine again well almost
the ref made mostly good calls and what
didn't you like my yellow card luckily
there weren't any unusual incidents I
was only worried about the snow in a few
places I didn't want the guys to get
hurt and then Eastern turkeys first
female referee is off the blaze some
more trails